hello everybody welcome to the last yce
I talk of the year and I'm pleased to
introduce to resealing back to Yale
after what 25 years Tori is coming from
the University of Utah and he's been
there since 1979 and he studied the
geochemistry or geochemical records of
changes in ecosystems related to changes
in climate and and looking at changes in
both plants and animals and today he'll
be talking about environments of human
evolution the isotopic evidence I
imagine from East Africa thank you thank
you it's it's it's a great pleasure to
be here again
I think the last time I was here was
probably about 10 years ago and I've
been here many times before that and
I've always enjoyed my visits and you
know as with everybody else in the room
I'm sorry that Karl's not here because
I'd love to have his feedback can he was
always willing to give it so so if
there's been a unifying theme of my
research over the years it might be
related to evolution of humans I first
went to East Africa as an undergraduate
working in the Turkana basin and I've
been there a number of times since and
one of the things that I have been
interested in all along is in
geochemistry and one of the sort of the
spirit of this talk will be in in how
I've tried to approach answering a bunch
of the questions that keep being posed
in paleoanthropology by by pipetting
anthropology colleagues and so we'll go
from there and I'll do
just start out remembering that one of
the things that I really loved about
listening to Karl talk was that he
always tried in his lectures to make
sure there was something for everybody
in the room and so you know for those of
you who've never seen anything about
isotopes this is what we're dealing with
there's a stable isotopes most of the
carbon on the planet is stable carbon-12
and a little bit as carbon 13 at about
1.1 percent and there's a tiny bit of
the other stuff which isn't important
and it's just simply due to the
difference in neutrons in the in the
carbon nucleus and the terminology is
the normal Delta c-13 terminology and
the ratio of whatever it is we're
interested in compared to whatever
standard we're using and on earth
remember that the total range is about
is in the second decimal place and and
our units on earth arranged we the Delta
c-13 ranges from about minus 65 to about
minus plus or to about plus 25 per mil
and then the main target of my talk
today or the main subject will be carbon
isotopes and I'd like to put it in the
context of human evolution this is a
diagram taken off the web of somebody's
representation of human evolution
starting with an early hominin in this
case artificer coos at about four and a
half or so million years ago and the
humans having split off from the
chimpanzees somewhere down here and as
we march up the geological record we
come to Australis asana menses and then
offer incest and platy ops is stuck over
here but some people might stick it in
the same line off in the direction to
some really robust officer pista singh's
hospital scene boys I or paranthesis
boys eye and the robustus which is a
South African similar creature and then
a bunch of homo species again depending
on how many
people or who's making the diagram and
the one thing I learned in geochemistry
is just keep out of that business I just
tell a geochemical story and you'll make
enough enemies without offering opinions
as to which species is which but it
leads up eventually to us and in East
Africa we have most of the fossils that
can be well dated and the question that
constantly comes up is what is the
environment look like
and here's just several environments
across Africa ranging from a fairly open
grassland to coastal forest and one of
the questions is well what is the
environments in which the humans were
living or the early hominins were living
and so on and there's lots of people
that I can thank and there's a many of
those are graduate students people with
the National Museums of Kenya and so on
and a bunch of different organizations
that have helped fund the research over
the years in various sorts of ways so
we'll start with the fossils it's kind
of gratifying in looking at this
collection of fossils that of all of
these skulls only this one was found
before I went to Easter Cana this one
was found in 1969 and when I as an
undergraduate took a course in evolution
you know none of these none of these
guys had yet been found and so it's been
gratifying seeing how this system has
built up and it's just in another early
hominin without his skull here's the
geology the basin is extraordinary this
is in the Shang gora formation and this
ridge on the skyline and
Ridge on that skyline are both layers of
volcanic ash this is a 2 meter layer of
volcanic ash and these layers of
volcanic ash provide us with the
chronology that that that we can use and
there's there's a lot of a lot of
geology in this room here's a couple of
the other people in the in the in in in
the group even Richard Leakey myself and
Frank Brown with an anthill for scale a
couple of former students been passing
11
vadik at high tide and also John
Harrison Ian MacDougall here's the
geology of the basin it's it's fairly
large Lake Turkana is is this large lake
here and look now because this lake is
probably going to be gone in the next 10
years there's some gigantic sugar cane
developments going on in the lower homo
Valley with a lot of people being
displaced in a large dam being built and
it's I think this lake will probably be
gone or almost completely gone in about
20 years
seismic data tells us that there's up to
3 or 4 kilometers worth of sediments in
some parts of the basin so this is in
the northern end of the lake but there's
a lot of outcrop space all of these
yellow stuff pretty much is the his D is
most of the outcrop with E and so again
here's the this this part here is the
lake okay and we've got some outcrops on
the margins and then we have some
outcrops down the axial drainage of the
Omo River so the Omo River drains
Ethiopian highlands yeah it's about a
quarter the size of the Blue Nile and
flows into the Rakata basin where it
evaporates into nothingness and the long
scale this
a large volcano that was built about two
million years ago so prior to two
million years ago this was a primarily a
flooville system that then drained out
to the Indian Ocean since this drainage
blockage occurred there's been periodic
capture and diversion over to the Nile
River system so it's kind of switched in
and out of this Basin for about the last
two million years for scale this is a
field area and over on this side I've
put all of the gasoline stations where
you have to do it that make so that
makes logistics difficult I think that's
the easy way so think of trying to do
field work in this area with only a
single gas station at your availability
and actually a large lake in between and
a border between two countries that
don't get along and the third country
South Sudan is kind of in here as well
so they're kind of some interesting
logistical challenges to think about and
then lastly in perspective here's the
size of the basin and I've kind of
circled this is the entire outcrop of
Olduvai Gorge and all of the principal
outcrops in the eye wash in Ethiopia and
at the same scale is the Turkana basin
so all of the other sites can easily fit
into just this Koobi fora outcrop area
or the nacho GUI or the lower Omo and so
on so it's a it's kind of a large area
to work out the geology and again
logistics make it in to make it
interesting what helps us out
terrifically are these layers of
volcanic ash like this one here and
using originally I started working with
Frank Brown on the correlation of
volcanic ashes and I found it frankly
very tedious and I'm just glad that
Frank has carried on for
very many years and has been able to
correlate many ashes within the basin
and outside the base and this is just an
example of one volcanic ash which we can
find in the Turkana basin in the
sediments it's also been found we've
found the source area of the volcano
it's been found in the AH wash it's been
found out in the Gulf of Aden and in the
western Pacific Ocean it's been found
down at Lake Baringo and it's been found
in the in the Albertine rift over in
like Albert so this is kind of the
extent of the layers of volcanic ash and
they provide nice timelines and again a
perspective perhaps at least to graduate
students
heõs we are looking for these promises
and they provide the material which we
can date and when I was a graduate
student we had to fill up this entire
bottle with these little crystals and
now we can date single crystals and that
makes not only life a lot easier
it means that there's a lot of things
that we can date that we couldn't date
before so over the years we've developed
exquisite chronology and the red dots
spread out through these various
sections just so all of the all of the
ashes which we've been able to date and
the black oblongs just show various
paleomagnetic intervals and there's been
a few ashes that have been traced into
the deep sea like these two that have no
isotopic date but we can constrain the
age based on the on the orbital tuning
of the deep-sea records so and taken all
together there's about 200 or 250 layers
of volcanic ash that we can correlate
between section and sections so we have
an exquisite opportunity to look at to
look at evolution in this case evolution
of
of humans and I should mention that a
number of these have been tied into
other sites such as the awash Valley in
Ethiopia there's probably about 10 or 15
volcanic layers that also help constrain
the ages of that system so there's these
various sites that I'll be talking about
today so the question that we always get
as geologists and we've been getting
from our colleagues for a long time is
how hot is it and and until a few years
ago in the terrestrial the the in the
terrestrial record often it was hotter
than this or less hot
and likewise oh it was it was wetter
than now or drier and what did animals
eat this is usually based on morphology
what kind of vegetation was present and
I was at Olduvai Gorge with a colleague
who picked up a stone tool and he looked
at the stone tool and he looked at me
and he said was the hominid who made
this sitting in the shade and I said oh
my god he wants to know if it was a
shady day and I looked at him and I said
Rob if you can tell me the time of day I
can tell you if he was sitting in the
shade okay so it's his job now to figure
out the time of day but I still have
left with this problem of how much shade
so what I want to talk about is using
isotopes to look at ecology in the
tropics and we're going to use our good
friend carbon 13 and we're gonna look at
c3 and c4 plants and we've done lots and
lots
hundreds and hundreds of c3 and c4
plants from Africa and we get these to
these two modes
of stable isotope values which are the
c3 in the c4 plants so this is a
collection of c3 plants and this in
front of the elephants is a collection
of c4 plants with a little concentration
of c3 plants running in a linear line
down the down that stream valley so
let's recall that c3 plants are the
early photosynthetic pathway on earth
something like 3 billion years old it's
most not all but most dicots so when you
plant a beam and it comes up and in as
two leaves that means it's a dicot it's
the cool season grasses so that's like
Kentucky bluegrass in my yard which is
just doing very well right now and when
you go to the grocery store it's the
vegetables the fruits the beans and then
these grasses wheat barley and rye or c3
grasses in an animal that eats c3 plants
looks into isotope space like a c3 plant
and then the c4 plants are the tropical
grasses and sedges and these two things
kind of need to go together we need to
have a monthly we temperature with
enough moisture for a growing season so
it has to be hot in the summer hey and
then we'll gut c3 grasses and sedges
favored so it's pretty rare and dicots
that if we go to again to the grocery
store maize corn sorghum sugarcane go to
the specialty market part of the grocery
store millet calf fonio and then if you
go to the meat counter and you buy
Tyson's chicken and you run it through
the mass spectrometer you find it just
looks like a bunch of corn any Tyson's
chicken everywhere in the United States
looks like it's just corn
hmm okay so shade what can we do to
answer this question about shade the
first question that we want to look at
so can we quantify shade this is part of
the I talked to the isotope composition
of shade so here's three scenes from
Africa one is about 1% and about 20 and
basically a hundred percent woody cover
so I'm just gonna redefine the variables
and we'll just call shade woody cover
okay so what he cover is something that
we can that we can actually measure so
that's woody cover this is what he
covered that bush in the background up
there is woody cover and of course
everything here is woody cover and so
perhaps we can use that to to help us so
basically shade we've now made this into
a binary instead of calling it c3 and c4
we'll just call it shade and this Plus
this is not shade okay and and we can
see what we come up with so what we did
in a number of sites following the work
of Michael Byrd we looked at about 76
sites from the tropics about 35 of these
are from from Africa and then also using
some sites where Michael has done a lot
of work in northern Australia in Zambia
and Malaysia so we just take all of
these sites together and try to quantify
the stable isotope composition and we'll
look at what we can call gap samples
where we collect samples between the
gaps in the canopy and we'll collect a
bunch of samples from underneath
canopies and measure the crown canopy in
the field and it turns out we can use
we've measured it a bunch of ways we
measure it by measuring it in the field
we can measure it from satellite
photography we can measure it using
upward looking cameras and they all give
essentially the same the same that the
the same value for the percent canopy
cover or percent shade covering the
landscape and conveniently it turns out
that the isotope composition of What's
in these gap areas and actually what's
under the canopies are actually rather
similar and with some thought it's
actually not that surprising you can
imagine as we make this gap smaller and
smaller and smaller than actually the
environment that is underneath this very
small area between the gouges rather
similar to underneath the canopy and
likewise as we expand this gap we see
that there's more and more sunlight
could get into open trees and so we find
that in fact they turn out to have not
identical but similar values and then we
can measure from satellite imagery the
percent canopy and percent open area and
use these isotope values to get an
overall isotope value of the ecosystem
or of the soil so this is just an
example 1% 21 and 99% woody cover and we
had about 35 sites sprinkled around
Africa from coastal forests mountain
forests deserts grasslands ecosystems so
whatever wherever we could find and in
fact it turned out that most of these
sites actually had been chosen for
different reasons so we kind of think of
them almost as not quite as random
samples but but the original selection
for each of these sites was actually for
a different project which I'll talk
about in a little bit anyway so we have
many many sites we can get the Delta C
13 of pure C for ecosystem
than a pure c3 ecosystems and we can fit
it to an arcsine transformation so we
end up with this as sort of a curve and
one of the interesting things is we have
very few c4 plants until a woody cover
is less than about 70% and that's
basically as we'll see it's because you
actually the soils in the environments
don't really get really really hot which
is what one of the things that c4 plants
are adapted to when you have extensive
woody cover so we can calculate a
probability density function for a given
Delta c-13 value so for instance Stealth
with c-13 value gives us a distribution
function and so what mostly what I'm
going to talk about is what these
distribution functions look like so we
can now go to the fossil record and we
use fossil soils and it would actually
was one of the earlier projects I
started working on in East Africa was
the fossil soils but without the woody
cover in ocean and here's two different
sequences of fossil soils llengua in
green and the nacho GUI could be floral
formation in red and this is I forget
how many fossil soils this is but it's a
lot several hundreds one of the things
that we notice is that okay the sugar or
formation is in the axial trough of the
Turkana basin where the Omo River is
today and this is we see that for the
early part of the record it's much much
more wooded than the marginal stream so
nacho GUI and kuba forum are both on the
on the edges of the basin are marginal
streams flowing into the into the trunk
stream homo trunk stream at about 1.8 or
so million years ago they seemed to come
together this is after the building of
the big volcano edifice okay so at about
this point is when there's a drastic
change in Basin configuration and we see
throughout this whole sequence that we
never really have closed forest we do
have some of this forest woodland
habitats a lot of the wooded grassland
habitats and we never actually see any
pure open grassland habitats and we can
quantify these things because of the
convenience of satellite imagery yeah so
20 percent open cover actually looks
like this 40 percent looks like this 65
like that and sensing 80% looks like
that so this gives us we can probably
say that well all of this area in here
during the nautically
form and could be floor information it's
probably something like this early jean
Gora
probably something more like that in
terms of the habitats available and we
can go through the whole geological
record in both the awash in Ethiopia and
the Turkana basin and do all the Paleo
Sol's and see what we get
so this lighter blue here is the Cheng
Ora and the darker blue is the not chewy
cookie floral formation and so we see
that kind of early on it actually
appears like it more been more open
became somewhat more closed and then
somewhat more open again but never do we
actually have true open grasslands in
the same is kind of true in the in the
eyewash it's more open he comes a little
more close but still fairly open and
then more open again and never ever ever
do we actually find any paleo Saul
evidence for true forest and and that's
what to pay the cells are telling us
another thing we could do is take all
fourteen hundred almost alias all values
over fourteen hundred donate its
thirteen hundred eighty when I made the
slide and kind of see what this
distribution is like and this is now we
can parse this into woody dicots
seafloor grasses and then the
contribution of the c3 forbs and herbs
to these to these landscapes and and we
see that about 25 percent might be
called grasslands where grasslands the
technical African definition of
grasslands is from about zero to ten
percent woody cover so this is ten
percent
woody cover and these both are would be
grasslands we see that by far the
dominant environment recorded in fossil
soils when I pay I'm gonna back up one
here if this lets me back it up it won't
let me back it up how do I back up this
total is about twenty five percent but
it turns out that actually most of these
are from less than about a million years
old so it appears that the grassland is
there's the prevalence is this this is a
kind of an over estimate for most of the
time period I'm talking about and it
appears that there's more grass line now
from the fossil from the pedicel record
now than there ever has been in Africa
okay most of it was between 10 and 40
percent woody cover those kinds of
landscapes and if you're a hominid
thinking about food this is what you
need to be thinking that this is the
most important environment this is the
most abundant environment available and
if you're a hominid thinking of running
away from so you wouldn't get eaten it's
the same place
and a few 15 or so percent are this sort
of habitat most of these are actually
from the Shankara formation and we have
essentially no evidence for forests okay
less than 1% and actually it represents
less than one Pele us all so we have
essentially no evidence in the fossil
record for what would be a true forest
maybe they're there but they're not in
the things that preserve paleo souls so
this is just three different sites that
I've put in just to compare site called
can JIRA that's actually not outside
district conurbation site called Aramis
and a site called canna poi to show you
the probability density that the Paleo
Saul says can oh boy looks like
something like this basically woodland
shrubland bushland Aramis is much much
more open in kenjiro Hills extremely
more open in the kinds of environments
that those represent in real pictures
look something like this this for Aramis
and this for can Jarrah or for canta boy
and and that's what that's what the
Paleo Sol's are telling based on the
isotopes okay and again from the top
view useful if you're thinking about
what it takes to get away from anything
these are paired photographs or paired
images so this is a Google image from
that site Google from that site and so
on to give you the sense of what the
landscapes are like so lastly we've done
a survey this is of the present Omo
River that's okay the axial okay the
what's shaded in or what's what's shaded
is outside the deposition
Basin everything inside the gray is in
the active depositional region of the
Omo River today so we have this axial
marginal this accent of meander plane
here's old meanders from the Omo River
so the Omo is meandering from here to
here this is actually four meters below
this okay so if there's if there's a
flood this entire area will become
flooded in will get a small amount of
sediments deposited likewise much of
this is actually lower than the levee
so the levees on the modern river are
three to four meters high and as we go
down further we get into some other
stuff the active Delta is down to the
south this particular image that I have
is about five percent riparian forest
it's about 15 percent bushland which is
represented mainly by this it's about
fifty or so percent wooded grassland and
it's got about 30 percent or so true
grassland that's out in this area which
is actually rather similar to what we
just looked at in the fossil soils okay
so we've we've actually been able to say
something now something about the
landscape and in terms of of the
ecosystems and I'm gonna now get into
the problem of how hot what can we say
about temperature and and here's two
sites Nakuru Kenya mean annual
temperature of about 17 degrees Celsius
Turkana mean annual temperature of 29
degrees this is what it looks like today
okay where were the guys that made these
tools okay what was driving
environmental factors for weather they
decided to be in the
or not well maybe we can find out from
the soils here's a map of the world okay
just put into a bunch of different
places in the mean annual temperature
New York City or New Haven Connecticut
is right about here Death Valley is
right about here there's a bunch of
places hotter in Death Valley Lake
Turkana is actually in this last little
tiny box okay so if we drive around the
world and collect a mean annual
temperature of everywhere we find out
that today Lake Turkana is in the
hottest 0.1% of the spots on earth in
terms of mean annual temperature there
are places that get hotter daily
temperatures but for mean annual
temperature it's pretty hot um a couple
years ago I was there during a trained
at night and I remember we got up and
the local people in our camp were all
standing around shivering and blankets
and the temperature was 70 degrees 70
Fahrenheit okay so our friend here is
the clumped isotope thermometer which I
know a lot of you should be familiar
with here it's a key part of our story
we remember that's isotope thermometer
was invented because Harold Urey you
know 1947 presented a talk in which he
described this chemical reaction which
involved the exchange of oxygen 18 in
water with oxygen 16 in calcium
carbonate and he pointed out that if you
could measure the ratio of oxygen 18 to
16 in calcite and the oxygen 18 to 16
ratio in water you this was an
equilibrium constant and because
everything all equilibrium constants are
functions of temperature this meant that
there was a thermometer and so this made
geologists very happy until they
really especially those of us working on
land kept bashing our head against
things they well we just don't know what
the isotope composition of water is sort
of kind of stock and so John Eilert came
up with this elegant equation on top
calcite plus calcite goes to calcite
plus calcite which even non gia chemists
can love until we label it and when we
notice the labels that really are
appropriate we see what we're really
interested in is keeping track of all of
the different species of isotope
exchange so this has only only one
peculiar isotope oxygen-18 this one has
only one peculiar and carbon-13 this one
has no peculiar isotopes and this one is
too so we just need to keep track of
those and because everything is a
function of temperature if it's an
equilibrium constant oh wallah we have
another magic thermometer and in soils
the key reaction is calcium carbonate
forms to some mechanism and related to
the chemistry of the soil so we just
need to measure everything and this is
getting to be more commonplace that had
not been done ten years ago had not been
done but so this is the notion of the
clumped carbonate paleo thermometer and
the notion is as you should should know
or if you don't spend a lot of time
talking to huggies and she'll tell you
all of the details we look at the Delta
the difference between the measured
value and a random randomized value and
we find that it's a very laborious small
scale that's only a point two per mil
difference for our entire temperature
range and so this is a laborious
measurement but we can do it now and so
now we move to Lake Turkana and
so some years ago have when been Cassie
was finishing his thesis with me I
convinced him and John Tyler at the same
time it would be good if Dan would go
work in in John Aires lab and so this is
work was done with with Ben PSE and also
with Naomi Levin who was involved in
some of the Paleo small work we were
working on so we're interested in these
soil carbonates these soil carbonates
form at depth they're always below they
form below about 20 to 30 centimeters
within soils and what that means is that
it's the soil temperature they're
measuring they could record the soil
temperature down here not the soil
temperature at the surface and the daily
soil temperature down here is very small
okay so our results were as follows this
is the mean annual temperature of Lake
Turkana every fossil soil except to said
that it was much hotter a lot hotter up
to ten degrees Celsius hotter okay so
this led us to be a bit worried either
there's something wrong with our
understanding with the thermometer or
something so what our response was by a
bunch of these little hobo gizmos and
stick them in the soil and see what
happens so this is our first profile
that we measured over not quite a year
and we see that so the gray shaded area
is the air temperature the blue is at 25
centimeters and the black is at 50
centimeters and what we see is that in
the rainy season we soil where we get
the temperature dropping and this is
when we add water and we increase the
plant activity increases soapy co2 goes
up both of those promote
soyal both of those promote carbonate
dissolution then we see that as the
growing sea as the as the soils dry out
okay co2 actually goes down during this
period that promotes soil carbonate it
gets hotter that promotes soil carbonate
co2 so co2 goes down water goes down
soil temperature goes up all of those
promote soil carbonate we expect we
don't know for sure we're measuring this
in some experiments now but that soil
carbonate formation should take place in
the hottest time of the year in this
environment and we see here that
actually is basically 10 degrees Celsius
higher than the modern so those really
hot temperatures are are actually
possible to get so not the hottest
temperature but the average temperature
for a year for three different sites so
we looked at this in a forest up a till
arete and it's sort of a force it's
actually just a bunch of trees along the
edge of a long the edge of a lager and
in the bush and in the open areas have a
difference in temperature of about 6
degrees Celsius
likewise Samburu with it it's a little
bit higher so it has a cooler
temperature again 7 degrees Celsius
hotter in the open and in the forest and
a little less four degrees in Nairobi so
we see these open areas are much hotter
and so at least we have a better feeling
that perhaps this is telling us
something real and then the other
interesting thing that thing that was
really useful is we decided to put these
temperature pendants and a series of
temperature at a series of depths so he
measured them we we did about 40 or so
sites where we measured them at 5
centimeters at 15 at 25 centimeters taps
and these are the curves that we observe
so rad is at 5 centimeters okay this is
just a
typical day and green is at 15
centimeters again typical day so the
amplitude is falling as we go down in
the soil okay now what we can do Hills
Hills and I always you know tell tell
people like me who you know appreciate
math but really don't do it as well as
as I wish I could make friends with a
geophysicist and so I you know talk to
Dave Chapman my colleague who works in
heat flow and he says well we we've
solved a similar sort of thing and it'll
just take a while to reprogram and let's
see what we can do and we can actually
calculate we can activate the input
function that reproduces these three
curves so this dotted line is the
surface skin temperature that produces
the red lines and you notice that this
is up over sixty degrees Celsius okay
but we have to reproduce all three of
those curves and we can do this every
day of the year
for every single site so here's a site
that we did in the grassland in an open
bush area and in a forested area and the
green represents every single day of the
year
you know the up-and-down of the forest
temperature the up-and-down of the bush
area and the blue is the up-and-down of
the daily so we've taken these
temperature profiles and figured out the
daily skin surface of the earth that
produces the soil at depth
so we'll mace my student working on this
with me said well let's composite these
and we'll call this a composite day for
three months of the year and this is
what it looks like for Meru so this is
what the skin surface of the earth looks
like to produce the soils on average for
three months so in the riparian forest
this is the temperature structure and in
the bushland this is the temperature
structure and in the grassland
this is the temperature structure so it
gets up to and then these envelopes are
one Sigma distributions so it
occasionally gets up to 60 degrees
Celsius and intra kana or it's even
hotter than narrow up to 70 degrees
Celsius is very common and I know Andrew
Hill who's sitting somewhere in the room
here can testify to that
that you know people have burned their
feets literally burn their feets when
they are newcomers and arrive and don't
realize how hot the ground can be and
they think oh I'll just go down to the
lake and they're sorry so come back to
the question of where these guys sitting
in the shade when they were making these
so let's at least consider a time of day
that is let's just a me a 40 degrees
Celsius is your cutoff okay then if
you're in the open grassland at midnight
it's dark and it keeps in it's still
dark and it gets a little cooler until
about 6:30 in the morning and then the
Sun comes up and by about 9:00 o'clock
in the morning it's 40 degrees Celsius
100 degrees and it gets up to over 260
degrees Celsius and then it comes down
again and about a 5 o'clock at night it
gets down to 40 and then it gets dark ok
so if these guys are in the open they
have only this window of time in which
they are not in the shade and it also so
my feeling is that if hominids out were
they at least had to be as smart as
goats
so here's goats in the middle of the day
and you see they're all in the shade so
now we know we're hominids were every
hour of the day or at least we can put
some constraints on where they might be
so another thing that we worry about is
aridity how hot or dry or something is
it and our notion conceptual model
working with Naomi Levin was that week
look at oxygen-18
and we know that meteoric water doesn't
really know very well about how dry it
is rainwater but lakes as they evaporate
lose the light isotope so they become
Richton the heavy isotope in the drier
it is the more enriched they become so
what would be nice would be to look at
some system that looks at the difference
between new york water and evaporated
water now it turns out that some lakes
are so small you could hardly call them
a lake and and botanists call those
leaves okay so leave a leaf is a
microscopic lake okay so then if we
consider well if there's something that
can preserve that signal of the leaves
because it's a water source then one way
to do would be to consider this
difference and so what we did is
subtracted hippopotamuses from giraffes
so our paleo rittany index is start with
a giraffe subtract one hippopotamus and
you have aridity all right
and so we've calibrated this by looking
at areas with both hippos and giraffes
in this is only River hippos Turkana is
the most evaporated this is from the
lower Omo hippos and giraffes and as we
get down to in fact a grazing or
browsing actually the okapi giraffe in
the Ituri forest so we find this isotope
separation collapses or much much
smaller as we get to more and drier and
drier area so the water deficit is the
difference between the precipitation
okay so evapotranspiration potential
evapotranspiration
- precipitation so in modern terms okay
we've seen Turkana Tsavo
nairobi Ituri forest and in the fossil
record we basically get most of our
samples are in between the hottest and
some areas that are still fairly dry so
we're not finding evidence for music
environments vegetation we've really
pretty much already talked to and we've
talked about the biomes so we don't see
any of this kind of stuff no no evidence
of forest we see everything in this
region we know that our rivers so
perhaps very small narrow riparian
corridors could explain these things so
the last thing I want to turn to is is
diets and look at our foods go to the
grocery store get some nice healthy
foods see three foods nice healthy see
four foods and so everything over here
these are these are all c3 foods this is
Taff the Ethiopian flatbread and some
guys collecting teff in the field so
again we can use this isotope
distinction you are what you eat plus a
few per mil and look at what the
homonyms ate so there's a story a lesson
for some graduate students that are here
when I first wanted to do this I wrote
to him Eve Leakey in 1990 because I was
going over to East Africa I said we
caught this great thing we can do paleo
diets of animals
let me have some fossils so she said
okay you know you can have whatever we
collect in a one-week period everything
you can take great because we've already
collected all the stuff we want from
this area and these are the scraps so we
in in to me by Christmas I had
demonstrated that this was fine so it
took another 10 years
to convince the scientific community
that actually tooth enamel was recording
paleo diets and then it took another 10
years to convince the museum people that
I should be able to sample hominid
fossils so it's 20 years from the
inception to being able to carry it out
and and and in defense of the museum
I'll say that except for the past five
years the last five years the first 15
years we definitely were damaging their
fossils more than I liked but that last
little bit I remember when the museum
curator said now where did you take the
sample and I knew that I had done so so
this is the first stuff that we did with
paranthesis so this is Homo Turkana
marine go pan Inge old of I to about a
thousand kilometers north to south over
a limited time window and it's this
paranthesis boys I Nutcracker man Nick
van de Merwe had just published some
results suggesting that these guys were
eating c-4 plants and it was not not
well received for a variety of reasons
and so we thought well we'll just try
this on all the samples that we are
allowed to sample from Turkana basin so
this is the Nutcracker man and he has
this big sagittal crest on his head and
big diameter teeth so that's that's
their teeth and this is our little bean
see tiny teeth the same tooth stick an
Amal speculated diet tubers not seeds
various sort of things so in 2007
Bernhard wood and authors wrote about 50
years of evidence and analysis so so far
there's been a lot of speculation 50
years of speculation and you know
isotope stuff so wow what do we get 22
individuals it was expected that that
would be in this area
and it was quite clear and fortunately a
rather small distribution of delta c13
valleys very narrow distribution of
diets that can only place it in c4 land
these guys were competing with zebras
and warthogs for diets not competing
with anything in the browser spectral
thing or even in the non grass or
Bhatia's vegetation these guys were
almost very close to pure grazers and
may have been pure grazers I remember I
took this picture some years ago before
we did this work of these baboons
sitting in this grassy field there
picking out the corns which are the
underground reproductive organs of these
because they're full of nutrients and I
don't really know yet what paranthesis
was eating but yet they're probably
doing more like this and having to eat
in that environment than in any
certainly not they were not eating in
any closed habitats when we finished
that we got the go-ahead from the
National Museums of Kenya to sample the
rest of the hominins in the museum that
had broken teeth so we only worked on
broken teeth and in last year we came
out with a series of papers early
hominin diets this is just an example of
one of the broken teeth and that's the
sample afterwards after I've collected
it and this is the surface before we
collected the sample and the surface
after we collected a sample so so so so
that's at least for this isotope
analysis what we're what we're doing so
all the hominid and diets from 4 million
years ago we find the earliest one
Austin petha seen Ottomans this is down
here in c3 land Ardipithecus
is not shown here but Ardipithecus is a
tiny little bit older and essentially
the same isotope values by the time we
get to austin petha seen afarensis this
is not this is actually the sample from
Kenya which the local paleontologists
called Kenya antipas planty Ops has very
wide isotope range and it's actually
identical to the isotope range of offer
Ensis a suggestion that maybe this is
two populations we're not sure two diet
populations and not sure but clearly by
two million years ago we've split into
two different diet categories this is
the home old group and the blue is the
per anthropos group so this is the big
nut cracker man what's a large sagittal
crest and this is Homo and and that's
what that's what the isotopes are
telling so now we're at the position and
when he wrote this paper we decided okay
we are not going to speculate in this
paper what the height guys were actually
eating we're gonna let the the isotope
analyses and speak to them speak out
loud if you want to complain about this
paper complain about our analyses we
won't actually speculate on the diet
except c3 based versus c4 based but so
now we can actually begin to speculate
and and again that's what I know what
I'll get in trouble with paleontologists
and pianoman topologists but this is
evidence any diets have to fit now into
this isotope space okay so we at four
million years ago we're it's eating pure
c3 foods it's not closed-canopy foods we
have an isotope signature that tells
about closed-canopy foods it's
definitely not closed-canopy foods we
have by three and a half million years
ago these two hominins leading to us
presumably both had quite a variety a
very wide range of a mix c3 and c4 diet
and by two million years ago we split
into homo
that's about 50% c4 based and per
anthropos about 80% c4 based moving up
another half million years both of them
increases small amount in c4 based
resources and now we need we need more
samples to look at what happens after
that okay so in kind of summary isotopes
have been really helpful in telling us
things that probably is a habitat that
looks like more like this with maybe a
repair with a narrow riparian corridor
okay that makes up only a few percent of
the total depositional landscape okay
number a deposition a landscape is the
entire width of the depositional region
which today in the omo is about 30
kilometres wide was mostly hot and dry
and and it's very clear that early
hominins from three and a half million
years ago to present we're using
extensively savanna resources in their
diets so if they're eating it they had
to be out out in it there could be some
other things that stay that stay in any
repairing corridor but it was not our
there was not the hominins from three
and a half million to present and then
lastly we can actually begin to think
about how they could possibly parse
their time use their time by thinking of
things in this notion of a composite day
and what sort of temperature temperature
regimes they'd experience again not air
temperature measured by a thermometer or
by a weather station but the real
temperature is measured by the bottoms
of your feet okay so it just closed with
one of my favorite images of a bar in
the small town of archers post showing
another view of hominid evolution coming
out of the trees and and and that's an
artist rendition and
I'll just close with that because
there's always people think that I lead
them astray and that's all I'm saying so
is there a difference in the thickness
of the enamel that you sampled between
whatever you were able to get ahold of
what I'm thinking is that certainly our
metabolic system is very similar it
really hasn't changed we still have
teeth they still have three different
materials in there all calcium phosphate
but what I'm interested in did the
actual enamel change in composition and
was it thicker or thinner depending on
what they ate it so were anthropos ways
I the ones of the really large sagittal
crest have really really thick enamel
and in some case in really old
individuals you could see that they'd
gone through all of it so yes there's a
there's a definite evolution in the
morphology of the teeth including the
thickness of of the enamel following
through on that is there's previously
there's been a bunch of studies done on
Micra wear of some of these early
hominin teeth but when we came out with
the per antipas thing it was such a
surprise to everyone that I think we
just need to start all over with the
micro air and say well now you know what
what is it really telling us because you
know you did it on these guys for many
years and it got wrong so if you really
Andrew he'll really be able to tell you
about the morphology of teeth yes every
detail
this traditional picture in my mind is
that in the early Pliocene climate in
East Africa was relatively wet and then
it became more and more arid and that
contributed the course of human
evolution
so is this picture wrong according to
this work yes
so I'd say that you know 50 years ago
there was a notion of all the savannas
opened up in the late Maya scene and
then about 25 years ago that fell into
great disfavor and I'd say that this
looks much more like the original notion
of 50 years ago that you know it looks
it looks like an open habit it's not the
same open habitat as today and I think
one of the things that we need to
realize is that c4 grasses today make up
50% of the net primary productivity in
the tropics so 50% of photosynthesis on
land is c4 plants at 10 million years
ago was less than 1% we have no fossils
there's not a single grass fossil in the
last 10 million years from tropical
Africa or elsewhere that I know of so
they also were undergoing
extraordinarily evolutionary binge as it
were and right now we don't know what
was going on we have some evidence from
genetics that Oh some things were
happening but the timing is terrible
because we you know it's basically tied
to whenever you think the first grass is
evolved where the first grasses showed
up with a linear genetic variation in
between so I I think if we can figure
out a way to understand what's happening
within the grasses we might have a much
better idea of
that's reckoned from East Africa I don't
remember the timing but again in my mind
it seems went to dusk it could indicate
it was less - given the amount of dust
and the record this increase in coming
towards the present a little bit yeah
somewhat more but I don't
the conditions were these two where some
yeah and and most of the dust record is
coming off of the Sahara it's not coming
off of you know what we're trying to
describe what is this area where we know
we have the hominid fossils not what was
somewhere else we don't have the hominid
fossils so we have to hominins at two
million years ago okay
at least one of them was definitely
hunting or at least not hunting but at
least butchering animals and whether
they hunted them or not or managed to
just scare off lions and and and envy
scavengers but so there was definitely
at least one of them was using was using
meat and a foot I have my guess that'd
be fake human ones that were doing that
the other interesting thing to me is
that if you look at the history of
grazing in Africa at two million years
ago we had two grazing elephants in
Africa they're both gone okay one one
became a browser we had to but we have
three grazing pigs okay
and now there's only one grazing Pig in
the entire continent we had one grazing
giraffe and that became extinct we had
to
grazing I think the per anthropos was
probably a grazer there was also a giant
primate baboon called therapist thickest
it was also a grazer
basically the non bothered grazers have
been pushed out of the picture they've
been there they're almost all gone it's
over it's almost as if two that had had
two million years ago we were still at
least down to the final four and I'm
gonna see what was happened but now it's
basically the boffins have pushed I
think it could be the Baba's that pushed
all the other grazers out of the picture
it is abrasive but there's a lot of
other abrasive things too and the most
abrasive thing is sand and so if you do
something with your remember us going
only a geologist who's crazy with you're
going through elephant poop one day I
was going analyzing elephant feces for
and I came across these samples that
were extraordinarily low in carbon I
thought that's extraordinary
and it turned out that these fur does
this this for a short period of time the
feces were about 25% sand but it was
right at the beginning of the rainy
season when they're having a hard they
pull up trees and shrubs and they whack
them on their foot to get rid of the
dirt they still eat the rest but I mean
that's a really abrasive diet so we do
find that I mean that's just a passing
example that you get sand in your
everybody knows what's sand in your
picnic food is like so but the and you
know Andrew probably has different
opinions on this than I do
sorry to put you on the spot Andrew but
you were there my first field season in
Africa but now I forgot where I was
going
sand sand sand in the picnic route yeah
yeah well that that over the the the
Micra where was a the Micra where diet
story just has not proven to be
interpretable and i think it needs to be
completely reconsidered and in certainly
in the context of what stable isotopes
are saying because they done it and they
got it 180 degrees wrong he's wrong as
you could get because they did not
nobody had suggested c4 grasses in the
diet yeah yeah yeah yes for this right
so the artificer this is one that is
being argued as to where exactly it's
being in the bipedality it's definitely
in c3 by its space and this earliest not
not based on it's not based on the
isotope evidence if you want that
evidence you've got it and then we have
to explain the isotope evidence how you
can
yeah so these were everything that I
showed was definitely bipedal now I find
your observation that the all these
grazers suffer disproportionately and
yet that's the new world that's emerging
ecologically right all these c4 grasses
are coming to da man and it looks like
per anther passes far better suited to
that than we are
where'd they go I know you want to
attribute this to Bob Ed's but I can't
help but thinking given that far more
monkeys die at the hands of other
monkey's than they do from all predation
combined yeah now you forget the lines
and tigers and bears it's obvious you
have to watch out for and do you think
that those paranthesis with this high c4
component that reflects that they're
eating animals that are eating c4 or
that they are themselves the great can't
say based on the isotope evidence and we
have to go to some other method and the
Micra where has you know I think lettuce
you know certainly do a lot of arguments
but it you know it really got things
pretty well wrong and so right now we
have to figure okay let's find some
other evidence we've put up this now we
say okay now what do we do to
distinguish between these these possible
different things it's almost certainly
c4 grasses or we're eating an animal or
eating animals okay okay and then if
it's eating animals we can say okay well
what animals and you know we're and
there's also crickets and things there's
also a lot of insects that could play
very important in this well let's
imagine if we look at the animals on the
landscape okay there's let's say tiny
animal small animals not quite but
almost all of the small mammals
rc3 so it has to be big animals it has
to be animals bigger than about 20 kilos
and speaking against this robust tooth
morphology that is making a large yes
right but it have to we seem to be able
to handle that very we'd have you they'd
have example T the C for animals that
they to see for animals available are
big P and they're pigs and they're
Bothans big boffins it has to be bigger
than like I say 20 kilos because all
basically almost all the mammals smaller
than about 20 kilos rc3
there's a few you can find an occasional
you know specialized mouse or something
that's unless you're a claw or different
unless you're it'd have to be large
animals so and that's fine but but again
that's a constraint that we can that we
can we can talk about so if you wanted
to be animals if you want to be mammals
it has to be large man has to be
learning yeah that's really interesting
well relatively large
yeah
new world dominated by the c-4 plants
and paranthesis up there doing a way
better job and we aren't would they go
yeah some termites they support depends
on them but yeah I have a question
ah that's the clumped isotopes question
oh no so I'm looking at this picture and
the soil is pretty whitish what makes
the soil at 50 centimeters depth so warm
and how does that translate to air
temperature is we have to go backwards
whoops even I went the wrong way
so the basically the problem is that in
the tropics things heat up very fast and
they cool down very slowly so we have
more heating so we usually think about
the daily soil temperature in terms of a
sine wave but it's not a sine wave it's
it's it's it's significantly distorted
where we have a high rate of heating and
a slow rate of cooling and so it's very
asymmetric and we get way way hotter
than the mean temperature okay and
that's just because of the the
absorption of heat by the surface of the
soil so yeah but so if we put a weather
station in each of those environments
that give us the same temperature that's
what weather stations are designed to do
that are designed to be always in the
shade and reflect as much sunlight away
as possible so a weather station in the
forest in the bush
or in the open actually will give you
the same air temperature so that's what
makes it tricky is is we need to now
figure out the next step and figure out
well if we want to relate it to meet
annual temperature what do we want how
are we gonna do that and and is is that
I mean yes but something we would want
but we'd also I'd love to have the mean
annual temperature I'd love to have the
soil temperature the mean annual soil
temperature and I'd like to have the
temperature on the first of July every
year you know so then the fossil soil
temperature and the modern soil
temperatures are similar yeah at least
that far we can say yeah